einfach ist es dumm hallo hier ist
wieder eure mal lange und willkommen zum
zweiten mal kommt auch schon zur ersten
kategorie und zwar recht sorge eure
instagram bilder
ich bekomme viele fan bilder auf
instagram und dieses mal habe ich mir
die what the [ __ ] ist dass bilder
ausgesucht weiß es nicht ganz genau was
ich zu diesem bild sagen sollen
warum wurde mein gesicht mit dem von flo
ausgetauscht wünscht ihr euch etwas
anderes hier haben wir schon etwas
kreatives keine nase und irgendwie macht
mir das bild angst aber gleichzeitig mag
ich es auch es ist verwirrend wie kommt
die braut hier kommt die braut hier
kommt die braut und warum ist es kelly
warum sich der mann
ich meine ich habe genauso gute
qualitäten warum bin ich rot warum warum
habe ich die augenbrauen warum
hasenzähne wird da sieht man das erst
auf den zweiten oder dritten blick dass
das das mirella und meine gesichter
vertauscht wurden ihr würden auch glaube
ich diese rotblonden haare stehen
die dunklen nicht so finde ich das ist
nicht so ihr ding diese bescheuerte
drugs lass uns über weitermachen
aktuelle sache nun zu denen ich etwas
sagen will
auch wenn es keinen interessiert
neonazis und das internet passend so gut
zusammen wie rotes t shirt und orange
hose ist die npd trier hat die npd trier
hat ein video hochgeladen wo sie dazu
aufrufen am ersten august im gibt straße
zu gehen und dagegen zu demonstrieren
dass in trier jetzt asylbewerber noch
mehr rein dürfen lasst die finger vom
internet
bleibt bei ihren plakaten mit ihren
komischen reimen aber wer das video
nicht kennt ich verlinke euch das mal
unten das ist echt so einfach ist zeigt
einfach was neonazis für menschen sind
vollhorst von vorne bis hin und weil sie
so dumm sind will ich eigentlich nicht
weiter darüber sprechen also hast uns
einfach mit dem nächsten thema wald im
rachen favoriten
mein erster favorit für diese woche ist
das neue album von kiz hurra die welt
geht unter ich bin kein musikkritiker
deswegen kann ich euch auch keine
richtige hatten feste bewertung gegeben
ich finde es nur genial
ich wünsche seit jahren kfz fan und
empfehlung und mein zweiter favorit ist
sarah hand gehen habe ich in meinem
letzten wanne will's wissen ausprobiert
wenn ihr das noch nicht gesehen habt in
der info karten könnt ihr jetzt darauf
klicken oder nach dem video anschauen
ja ich finde ihn super und das
videospiel perverser geworden als ich
das gewollt hatte also entschuldigung
falls sich jemand angegriffen gefühlt
hat geschichten aus der youtube welt
melina vom kanal live melina hat sich
als lesbisch geoutet ich finde das
großartig dass sie den mut hatte das
öffentlich bekanntzugeben
nicht weil lesbischsein ein schwerer
schicksalsschlag ist aber weil sie wohl
offensichtlich damit zu kämpfen hatte
dass auch für sich zu akzeptieren und
das auch ein zu sagen und ganz ehrlich
melina war mir noch nie so sympathisch
wie in diesem video ich finde ja dass
ihr diese etwas ruhigere und ernstere
art viel besser steht als diese aber das
ist natürlich auch geschmackssache
weniger cool fand ich diese woche den
guten zahlen des julia er möchte sein
und ja das darf er ja auch gerne ich
meine die musik der macht das jetzt
nicht so mein geschmack aber es gibt
bestimmt auch leute die das feiern also
warum nicht ich hab gestern sein neues
musikvideo live gesehen und was zur
hölle war dass du kannst keine 30
sekunden von diesem video sehen ohne
dass ihr nackter als gerecht geklatscht
wurde
schon jetzt denkt habe ich für euch mal
den buden
gespielt 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13
14 mal war so in der totale das so gar
nicht an uns mehr sehen konnte und das
war für mehrere sekunden und lag bei
thomann also ich glaube dass es eher so
der brust über kommen wir nun zu ihrer
absoluten lieblings kategorie das wetter
also ich habe hier nur das wetter für
berlin weil das sonst zu lange dauern
würde also am montag wird es sehr warm
32 grad danach und drei tage warten
angesagt also bewölkt und sonne und am
freitag und samstag wieder schön und am
sonntag gibt's reden
das wetter präsentiert von katzen
intonation kommen wir nun zur twitter
frage ich habe euch gefragt wenn euer
sommer ein song wer welchen titel hätte
hier sind eure viel zu depressiven
antworten ich hasse alle wenn die latte
und kein schwimmbad aber trotzdem happy
mit bier
die unendlichen weiten der länder
die unendlichen weiten belohnung gönnten
hast du sie bieten der text was mit dem
kunden einfach alles aber wenigstens
haben sie hier eine klimaanlage und
internet
der herbst ist einsam einfach praktesch
bist du réel man ich kann den gleichen
witz mich nochmal bringen jetzt bin ich
traurig
logan ich hoffe euch hat das zweite
sommerloch genauso gut gefallen wie das
erste und wir sehen uns dann schon ganz
bald wieder